[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Renault Muselier bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous dans ce
nouveau plateau vous le voyez président
délégué de région de France membre de
René sens en étant ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche qu'on est ravi de
retrouver bonjour Christelle
on a évidemment beaucoup de sujets à
voir avec vous renommer on va commencer
en disant un mot du Maroc frappé il y a
4 jours par un terrible séisme avec la
région Occitanie et la Corse votre
région Sud s'est très vite mobilisée
pour le Maroc pour verser un million
d'euros est-ce que cet argent a été
versé va être versé et à qui non les
programmé les trois institutions et mes
collègues présidents de région sont bien
entendu d'accord c'est parti à cette
solidarité du sud de l'Europe avec nos
amis marocains on est tous très liés
avec le Maroc dans leur bien entendu ces
moyens financiers vont être débloqués au
service de quoi et de qui et commun on
voit bien qu'elle est difficulté avec
avec le Maroc sur le plan diplomatique
mais ça renforce quelque part ne
sollicite toujours pas l'aide de la
France Emmanuel Macron dit qu'il faut
pas faire de polémique mais est-ce que
vous
dans la vie diplomatique qui qui qui a
un passif là avec un vrai passé de très
grands grands amis et quelques
difficultés et c'est peut-être
l'occasion aussi de dire en quelque part
de faire la paix des braves et de
profiter de l'occasion si je puis dire
entre guillemets pour se réconcilier et
montrer qu'on est qu'on est des peuples
frères il était ce qu'a eu des Marocains
on a toujours été une proximité majeure
nous dans le sud on a beaucoup de
Marocains que ce dans nos trois régions
respectives et nous avons des accords de
coopération décentralisés en réalité
avec les les présidents de région locaux
avec la mère de Marrakech nous avons des
accords et nous pouvons passer sans
nuire à la diplomatie française parce
que nous sommes des français mais aussi
aller aider c'est pour aux gens qui
souffrent dans ces dans ces travaux
l'argent que vous proposez bloquer c'est
ça
de travailler avec les ONG par exemple
on travaille avec Captain on va
travailler avec la Croix-Rouge qui est
implanté là-bas on à avoir les
meilleures interlocuteurs qui soient
politiques donc les walides ou les
présidents de région dans les
gouvernorats ou les ONG et puis il faut
faire très attention aussi c'est que cet
exemple solidarité majeur peut
l'habitude de ce genre de crise je sens
qu'il y a souvent des thrombose ou des
il faut pas il faut pas envoyer
n'importe quoi n'importe comment
n'importe où parce que finalement c'est
on n'est pas on fait une thrombose et au
contraire ça gêne on va revenir à
l'actualité mais par contre ces versets
c'est organisé c'est en cours de façon à
être de façon à être efficace et pas
traîné voilà on revient l'actualité en
France et à Marseille et je reviens il y
a tout le traitement de l'eau aussi qui
est très important il y en a mobilisé à
sauter le canal de Provence pour
apporter de l'eau acheminer de l'eau
dans les territoires difficiles d'accord
à Marseille dans votre région et cette
tragédie cette jeune femme de 24 ans qui
est décédée victime de tir aveugle près
d'un point de ville alors qu'elle se
trouvait chez elle un cran
supplémentaire a été franchi dans
l'horreur Gérald Darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur était chez vous hier à
Marseille il a déclaré qu'une unité de
CR s prendrait ses quartiers en novembre
est-ce que c'est suffisant
c'est tous les maillons de la chaîne
l'envie une situation qui est
désastreuse c'est pour aussi d'abord le
monde a rien travail chez elle c'est
pour une balle là dedans dans le cadre
la réalité c'est que depuis maintenant
près de deux ans
tous les points de vie sont attaqués
tout est attaqué donc espèce de grande
coup de pied dans la fourmilière de la
part de l'État français qui fait en
sorte que on atteint on attaque les
trafiquants sur les lieux trafic et donc
on rentre partout ils vont partout et
donc l'impression que ça améliore la
situation et donc au contraire ça
l'améliore ça l'améliore sur le fait que
l'État français va partout et qu'il y a
plus de zone de non-droits et donc on
réinvestit les quartiers sauf que quand
vous fermez dans le 33 ils essaient de
prendre par le marché fond des OPA sur
d'autres quartiers et c'est ce qui se
passe à Santis samedi c'est dans le
dixième arrondissement c'est une cité
plutôt sympa sans trop de difficulté et
mais comme justement c'est une cité
tranquille ils essayent de prendre la
cité pour essayer de parler
aujourd'hui de
moi je pense qu'il y a surtout on a des
moyens supplémentaires de police on a
des moyens supplémentaires de magistrats
c'est qu'il y a aussi une deux
politiques qu'il faut des milliards qui
ont été investi par Emmanuel Macron
il y a deux choses d'abord il faut il y
a pas que la justice police il y a aussi
tout le volet social qui est pas traité
par la municipalité fait rien donc on se
donc on sait pas ce qui se passe dans
les quartiers il y a pas très bien dans
cette situation il y a une
responsabilité de tous les maillons de
la chaîne donc chacun doit il doit
mettre sa contribution
le maire il est quand même c'est
l'autorité municipale où est l'autorité
municipale n'existe pas donc là il y a
une vraie difficulté parallèlement à ça
donc il y a le volet social puis après
il y a le volet de la consommation
il y a quand même un vrai problème par
rapport à la consommation donc euh on
peut pas avoir autant de consommateurs
autant d'argent dépensé simplement vous
demander à ce niveau ah je pense qu'il
faut arriver à faire vous savez quand on
regarde le covid on a réussi à faire des
tests partout tout le temps ce qui se
droguent ben ils participent au trafic
de
qui est tout seul dans son quartier a
besoin d'un traitement social d'une
aménagement de partir en vacances enfin
de la vie quand même il n'est pas
cantonné dans un quartier où il peut y
faire par sinon il est pris par les par
les trafiquants et devient dealer
lui-même et les montants financiers en
jeu sont terribles et parallèlement à ça
il faut aussi que les gens qui fument
qui qui fument parce que il y avait tout
le débat aussi sur savoir moi je suis
médecin savoir s'il fallait légaliser
sauf que c'est des points multidylle
enfin c'est des points de dit donc il
faut des sanctions pour les
consommateurs
très fortes parce qu'il participe au
trafic d'hommes au trafic d'argent ou
trafic de il a tout les trafics en fait
en réalité pour la petite plaisir
personnel de cannabis
des familles assimils étangs entre 50 et
100000 euros le point de villes par jour
donc quand vous avez quand même ça c'est
qu'il y a bien des gens qui dépensent
parce que eux ils vendent si on sait des
gros commerçants qui vendent un truc
illicite plus ou moins propre parce que
là dedans vous avez parfois du shit qui
est complètement pourri et qui vous
flingue le cerveau parce qu'il y a des
cons il y a aussi des dégâts sur la
santé mais mais ce qui consomme là c'est
bien c'est bien des clients quand même
qui viennent pour faire ça et cela ils
participent à cette démarche là et je
pense qu'il faut prendre la totalité de
la chaîne un collectif de famille
assimilettant en justice
en disant on a le droit aussi de vivre
dans toute sécurité dans ces quartiers
est-ce qu'il y a un manquement de l'État
aujourd'hui
je comprends je comprends
la réaction et et après tout c'était
moyen aussi d'interpeller et
d'attiration mais
avant ils étaient tranquilles dans leur
quartier et au pied des cités ils
terrorisaient la cité et il vendait leur
saloperies très bien aujourd'hui ils ne
peuvent plus le faire
parce que ils sont attaqués en
permanence par la police par les
attaquent les nourrissent etc donc il y
a vraiment une fonctionnement qui qui
est donc une respiration et donc il se
déplace puisqu'on a fait fermer je crois
24 ou 25 points de Deal mais quand vous
fermez 24 ou 5 25 points de 10 vous avez
des groupes de voyous de bandes
organisés très bien structuré avec des
moyens financiers aussi importants ils
vont essayer de se répartir ailleurs
d'autres territoires donc il faut
attraper le consommateur aider dans les
quartiers sanctionner et ça nécessite la
totalité et bien entendu les piquets à
l'international ce qui est le cas où je
suis aujourd'hui où ils sont pris à
l'international parce que les grands
patrons de la drogue sont là-bas
Christelle on parle d'un autre sujet
avec vous on parle de la question de
l'immigration oui plusieurs
représentants de la Nupe et de l'aile
gauche de la majorité ont publié une
tribune lundi pour défendre la partie du
projet de loi immigration qui concerne
les métiers en tension le régularisation
dans les secteurs en tension est-ce que
vous comprenez la crainte de ces élus
qui ont peur qu'en fait cette partie du
projet de loi se retirer
moi j'aurais pas signé la tribu mais je
comprends très bien le sens de la
tribune
Nicolas Sarkozy a dit plusieurs fois il
faut qu'on fasse une loi sur
l'immigration quand même on a des
pressions démographiques et des
pressions de crise sanitaires
d'expression de tout autour de nous et
on le voit bien ce qui se passe au Maroc
on a des pressions énormes et
donc on a la nécessité de faire une loi
dans cette loi qui doit rappeler un
sorte de choses moi je suis confiance en
Armanet sud d'armanin et à Madame borne
la réalité est quand même c'est qu'il y
a des gens ici dans ce pays qui
travaillent quand même
je suis là dans nos barres dans nos
cafés
dans nos vignes on a des étrangers
ceux qui sont en règle ceux qui
travaillent ce qui cotise il y a pas de
raison qui qui soit pas accepté dans
votre pays alors après il y a des
engagements politiques entre la nuesse
et les hommes de gauche de la majorité
etc moi je rentre pas là-dedans il y a
des gens de droite comme mon ami Lionel
Lucas
dure quand même et qui dit ceux qui sont
en règle et qui travaillent qui cotisent
comme moi c'est du bon sens
vous comprenez ça moi je comprends pas
la position derrière depuis longtemps
donc ils sont contre tout le temps à
partir de Macron le président de Macron
dit quelque chose ils sont contre donc
tout ça n'a pas de sens ça n'a pas de
sens moi je suis un homme d'ouverture
mais en même temps de créer un appel
d'air vous comprenez ça ou pas mais mais
moi je comprends surtout une chose c'est
que la crise démographique et la crise
et migratoire elle est là et que la loi
sur l'immigration il faut la voter et
que dans notre pays on a besoin dans les
emplois en tension dans la région
provençale-côte d'Azur nos barres nos
cafés nos hôtels nos restaurants tous
les métiers d'apprentissage nous avons
des immigrés en situation régulière qui
travaillent qui demande qu'une seule
chose c'est être intégré c'est de
respecter les lois françaises et de se
retrouver dans une situation où on peut
l'intégrer parce que il veut être
intégré c'est pas celui-là qui pose le
problème de sécurité ou de malveillance
ou de trafiquants cela il veut
travailler
à imaginer supprimer cette partie sur
les métiers en tension pour obtenir
l'accord des LR et leur vote à
l'assemblée de votre point de vue c'est
pas une bonne stratégie c'est pas ça lui
est dans une stratégie tactique pour
faire voter la loi et on est partis sur
un principe moral qui signé sur une
tribune politique des gens de
sensibilité de gauche mariés plutôt avec
l'extrême gauche ce qui me pose quand
même problème puisque c'est leur pire
adversaires à l'Assemblée nationale sur
le plan pratique sur le plan moral moi
j'ai pas trop de difficulté avec ça
c'est les gens qui respectent notre pays
qui travaillent notre pays qui cotise
notre pays qui sont en situation
régulière zéro souci ce qui font des
bêtises ceux qui font des horreurs ceux
qui font des et qui sont quand même
dehors voilà ça c'est réglé mais après
monsieur Darmanin est un homme politique
qui doit faire voter ses lois si il a
besoin et on voit bien la difficulté au
Parlement de trouver des équilibres mais
il faut qu'il fasse aussi des efforts
aussi là-dedans et c'est peut-être un
moyen pour faire d'autres patients et ça
c'est une tactique politique par rapport
à la première question qui était ce que
vous pensez que ça suffira si il retire
cette partie pour obtenir un vote DLR
qui en demande bien plus
la difficulté et vous avez en fait vous
allez bien remarqué avec je prends
l'exemple que nous avons vécu avec la
réforme des retraites dans le cas de la
réforme des retraites ils ont passé le
gouvernement un accord avec les LR bon
et à moitié délire qui sont pas voulu le
faire de la ferme et donc vous avez des
élèves de l'assemblée de l'Assemblée
vous avez l'air du Sénat quand vous
dîner avec du Sénat ils sont d'accord
pas d'accord il dit il respecte quand
vous ditez avec de l'Assemblée c'est un
canard sans tête il sait pas où ils ont
et donc il se retrouve dans des
situations
que ça soit monsieur Marleix que ça soit
monsieur sotti on voit bien ils l'ont
fait et c'est la difficulté d'exercice
pour le gouvernement ils ont dit les
avec eux dans la réforme des retraites
et ils ont pas pu tenir leur troupes
dans le cadre de la série
qui a dit il y a pas longtemps que de
toute façon il fallait dans l'opposition
totale bon donc ils n'ont pas ils n'ont
pas de structure politique de
gouvernement qui est donc qui se gâche
eux-mêmes puisqu'ils ont aucune capacité
d'avoir une réflexion de de d'un parti
gouvernemental mais tiens pas de partir
avec ce type pour vous
membres de l'assemblée et que les
parlementaires de l'Assemblée ne suivent
pas ces directives on l'a vu
il y a pas longtemps et ben non il tient
pas son parti
aujourd'hui chez les LR on parle de
possibilités de motion de censure sur le
texte immigration ou même sur le budget
là vous comprenez la stratégie vous
craignez qui mettent leur menace à
l'exécution moi je suis dans une logique
où je suis un homme de droite en ancien
LR où je pense que fondamentalement nous
sommes en partie le gouvernement quand
nous sommes en partie de gouvernement
quand on nous sommes pas d'accord ce qui
est le cas aujourd'hui moi maintenant je
suis je suis maintenant macroniste donc
je suis dans mon essence avec ma liberté
d'expression qui est la mienne que j'ai
toujours eu et qui vont pas m'enfermer
donc je m'exprime dans un parti où je
peux m'exprimer sur
vous avez une démarche où ils disent de
toute façon vous avez une génération qui
est en train de se sacrifier tous ces
jeunes là qui sont plutôt bons là
toute une série de jeunes qui ont un
compte 40 ans c'est assez facile à voir
bon tous ces jeunes qui sont là dedans à
partir du moment où ils sont toujours
dans la position systématiquement il ne
propose finalement rien puisqu'ils
peuvent rien appliquer et parallèlement
à ça ils finissent par voter des lois
parce qu'ils sont dans leur logique
c'est à dire c'est j'ai jamais vu un
parti qui arrivait à être
dépenser autant d'énergie à lutter
contre leur propre idée c'est un truc de
fou pour vous ce projet de moi il est
morné ou il a une chance d'être voté
de faire des abonnements si vous avez en
face de vous déjà raisonnable moi je
pense que c'est facile avec le Sénat
parce que
vous dites ça oui ou si ça non c'est
tranché et il y a cette habitude et
assemblée vous avez immédiatement à
l'intérieur de l'assemblée des gens qui
sont combat les uns contre les autres
donc ça peut pas marcher à Marseille
prochainement pour parler justement
d'immigration est-ce que son discours ne
vient pas entre choqué ce projet de loi
immigration justement vous savez les
catholiques qui sont quand même pour
pour aider les autres moi je suis
méditerranéen autant je me baignais
volontiers dans Méditerranée autant ça
me m'amuse pas du tout de voir que dans
le même bassin il y a des gens qui se
noie pour plus d'accueil
ça c'est la volonté du pape et c'est
normal c'est très bien moi je suis dans
une logique et je présenterai ça
grâce à sainteté quand il viendra à
Marseille avec Méditerranée du futur que
j'ai organisé avec tous les présidents
de région les walides les gouvernants
etc dire il y a plusieurs problèmes à
traiter on peut aider à traiter le point
de l'eau c'est
immigre parce qu'ils sont pas bien chez
eux quand même donc si on peut faire en
sorte de coopération indispensable et on
a une coopération très très importante
et facile à faire notamment pour l'eau
bon on a les points d'eau chez nous mais
encore plus chez eux donc quand vous
avez pas d'eau vous avez besoin de
démographie vous partez et vous allez
vous migrer quitte à risquer votre vie
donc le pape lui dit il faut sauver
c'est pauvres gens nous ici en France
c'est plutôt quand même on peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde et
moi sur le bassin méditerranéen je vais
peut-être les aider
les gens quand ils viennent chez nous on
fait des accords là pour les gens
d'extrême droite moi j'ai je vois bien
la pression migratoire que j'ai à mon
Genève
c'est en frontière et l'Italie j'ai des
migrants qui viennent d'Afrique et qui
passent là-dedans et l'hiver ils sont en
plein de il y a bien des passeurs qui
sont des êtres humains qui sont des
assassins quand même pour les mettre là
mais quand vous avez une femme enceinte
qui est dans la neige vous avez pas eu
mettre un coup de pied dans le ventre
comme elle m'a dit le Front national
quand même dans l'hémicycle chez moi
je la défense un mot sur la venue du
pape sous un autre angle est-ce que vous
redoutez les les mouvements sociaux les
perturbations à Marseille lors de la
venue du Pape on est en train de
travailler dessus de façon à ce que ça
se passe pas
on a on a abordé le problème dans le
cadre des des de la Coupe du monde de
rugby on a eu des préavis de grève pour
la SNCF en bas j'ai dit j'aurais dit
écoutez moi je peux tout comprendre sur
les problèmes franco-français enfin me
parasitait pas la dimension mondiale une
situation où on essaie d'accueillir des
gens qui viennent voir un moment de fête
et qui nous ont fait confiance pour
l'organisation donc ça on l'a plutôt
réglé puisque notre train roulé donc
merci
aux raisonnable de la SNCF qui auront
levé leur préalable on verra les
problèmes plus tard parce que c'est la
vie démocratique et syndicale française
pareil il y avait les taxis enfin vous
allez passer vous avez pas bloquer la
ville aujourd'hui pas on a pas eu depuis
1510 papa vous avez pas faire cette
connerie quoi sérieux donc ils ont
compris quand même la violence du truc
et donc ils ont un débat important à la
préfecture pour savoir si entre
Marignane l'aéroport et Marseille je
fais c'est pas sérieux ça c'est un vrai
problème peut-être enfin je je rentre
pas dans ce déballage
arrêtez et je crois que ça ça va être
réglé quand même donc
je pense que quand vous discutez avec
les gens et que vous êtes vous avez des
gens responsable Vous faites valoir vos
vos réseaux de morts et que vous traitez
les problèmes vous les régler les
problèmes donc ils vous font confiance
et donc moi c'est ce que j'essaie de
faire Christelle question sur les doigts
parlons politique Édouard Philippe a
accordé une interview à TF1 ce week-end
il fera sa rentrée politique à Angers ce
week-end quel regard est-ce que vous
jetez sur son parcours politique depuis
son départ de Matignon
moi vous savez je suis le plus vieux de
tous là dedans parce que moi j'ai
maintenant près de 65 ans j'étais tout
juste grandir là et c'est tous des
enfants derrière tous des enfants donc
beaucoup ont beaucoup de talents
honnêtement Édouard Philippe on fait
partie ils ont fait un choix qui a
beaucoup été critiqué parce que ça a
flingué un paquet députés à l'époque etc
en fait je peux constater quand même que
le Président de la République Monsieur
Macron a été élu de fois peut-être à la
surprise enfin il est président de la
République il a été élu parce qu'après
il était le cas de mon âme mon grand ami
Chirac mon patron et de mon Président
Sarkozy que j'aime bon très bien il a
été élu respect
là dedans ils sont au pouvoir il faut
pouvoir et qu'est-ce qu'on fait et ben
soit on fait comme Monsieur Philippe et
quelques-uns comme Monsieur le Maire
comme Monsieur Darmanin qui fait partie
de sa génération mais on contribue à
l'évolution du pays dans le cadre de ses
idées et que l'on défend au sein du
gouvernement soit on est toute la
journée en train de dire vous avez pas
être là vous êtes des traîtres vous
faites mal etc mais tu fais quoi toi
c'est ça la difficulté c'est pour ça
qu'il se gâche et donc oui c'est à dire
que qu'est-ce qui est marge on voit bien
qu'il émerge rien de chez les
socialistes
il y a le front national qui est
toujours là omniprésent avec la volonté
de Marine Le Pen et de Mario maréchal
conforte la majorité aujourd'hui pardon
ça démarche conforte la majorité
aujourd'hui
qui qui reste toujours dans l'opposition
stérile au point de les faire
disparaître selon vous ça c'est les
européennes les européennes peuvent
faire disparaître à l'air
que si
la dernière fois ils ont fait 7 avec
Bellamy on était fort quand même à
l'époque on a fait enfin on a fait ils
ont fait les présidentielles avec avec
Valérie pescres qui était quand même une
bonne candidate moins de 5 vous croyais
que Bel-Ami s'est renforcé depuis je
crois pas hein donc
si il faut moins de 5 qui sont quand
même ils sont ils sont ils sont ils
n'auront plus que leur territoire on en
a énormément d'élus sur la base qui sont
un peu perdus parce qu'ils se retrouvent
plus dans leur chef justement la
démission a signé à horizon était de
recruter d'anciens LR pour être une
porte d'entrée vers la majorité pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez le fait le choix
d'adhérer à Renaissance comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure
je me refuse maintenant avec mon
expérience de rentrer dans une écurie
présidentielle j'ai fait la Shira qui
profonde la Sarkozy j'ai fait les
combats contre ma maladie
présentiel parce que vous êtes dans le
parti du dans la République il est plus
candidat il n'est plus candidat donc
j'ai ma liberté mais vous étiez à la
rentrée si vous êtes chez Horizon vous
êtes mécaniquement avec Édouard Philippe
mais vous étiez à la rentrée de Gérald
Darmanin c'est pas une écurie
présidentielle Charles
aussi mais l'enjeu c'est quoi c'est qui
qu'un seul candidat à la sortie comment
il va
j'appelle géraldman
le maire le vendredi comme jardin
on peut pas dire qu'il fasse un mauvais
travail qu'est-ce que ferait de plus
aller à là-dedans dans la région de
droit dans cette culture de droite qui
est la nôtre là dedans vous pouvez
discuter de beaucoup de choses vous
faites globalement c'est des
personnalités qui pèsent dans le débat
politique et donc pesant dans le débat
politique à quel moment ils vont
s'entendre à son raisonnable pour que ce
pays ne dise pas dans l'extrême droite
voilà c'est ça mon gros enjeu moi c'est
je suis contre Alexandre
Erica a fait la même démarche que vous
hein ne pas adhérer à horizon et plutôt
choisir Renaissance est-ce que
finalement ça revient pas à vider un peu
horizon de de sa raison d'être non parce
que vous avez des regardez vous avez le
vice-président c'est Christian Estrosi
donc vous avez quand même des gros élus
locaux qui sont qui sont horizons parce
que ils sont dans une logique qui disent
ben ils sont plus plus proche de leurs
électeurs et donc ils vont plutôt chez
Édouard Philippe qui est quand même le
mieux placé aussi dans les sondages
apparemment et mes défenses mais la
route est longue et à la sortie il
faudra quand même trouver des moyens de
se retrouver tous tout le temps ensemble
pour ne pas perdre les présidentielles
donc vous voyez encore un accord
il faut toujours prêcher pour l'accord
moi je suis pour les additions
semble reprocher à Emmanuel Macron de ne
pas avoir de stratégie est-ce que vous
partagez la critique
c'est lui qui l'a nommé c'est lui qui
l'a fait quand même Macron président
il s'est pas fait jeter et donc il a
soigné sa sortie du gouvernement quand
même alors après est-ce que dans
Philippe a fait tout ce qui était
parfait et bien
c'est difficile quand au pouvoir de
toucher une stratégie claire aujourd'hui
d'Emmanuel Macron pour essayer son pays
oui je l'ai vu cet été encore et il est
de son pays il donne du mal
mais l'initiation politique compliquée
dans la mesure où
on est plutôt dans un parlementaire un
peu comme à l'Europe c'est à dire que
vous avez une majorité relative et vous
devez vous entendre avec des groupes
différents et dans la culture française
ça n'existe pas au Parlement français ça
donc on arrive pas à voir cette culture
de dialogue et des gens pour arriver à
faire des retraites et créer une vraie
clivage avec le président
la réforme de retraite a créé un vrai
prix qui va à l'Assemblée nationale à
l'intérieur de la nupes et à l'intérieur
de LR et donc complique entre les
mécaniques
il avait dit dans la campagne et
peut-être que les Français ne le
souhaitaient pas mais ça va être
tellement je suis pas sûr qu'elle était
très bien vendue la campagne non plus la
réforme mais globalement vous pouvez pas
dire aux gens vous savez vous allez
travailler plus gagnez-moi ça ça marche
pas
merci beaucoup
Christelle de la dépêche et le covid le
retour de la vaccination ton corps est
toujours elle a une de la dépêche merci
Christelle on passe au cas où